hello hello it's it's 1:00 and so we're
going to go ahead and start uh finance
division 3 today's uh another
informational hearing uh we're going to
hear from the dep Department of Health
and Human Services on the topics of U
DCF elderly and Adult Services services
for individuals with disabilities or
mental health substance use
disorders um and then at the end I'm
going to allow the public to comment if
there's anyone that's come in and wants
to make a comment um uh the reason that
we're having these hearings before the
budget is released is that these are
areas in which um we have a very uh
strong uh two two things occur we we we
invest a significant amount of General
funds in these areas and with our our
budget issue coming up we have to really
be very careful and look very carefully
at where we're spending General funds
and also this is an area where uh the
the proportional share between General
funds and the federal government uh just
suggests that there's there's um a a
bigger percentage than in other
Departments of General funds to um
federal funds so so these are these are
areas that we we need to start taking to
look at and getting to understand uh
very carefully because of those things
um before we get
started uh with the Department I'm going
to I'm going to um surprise
representative
walner and say earlier we talked about
um arranging a visit to Waypoint and
since that was the most recent hearing
we've had let's let's just wrap that up
and see if we can figure out when we
might take a tour do you want to talk
great they they would um welcome us to
come down and see the
shelter and I just thought it really
would depend on what our work schedule
is here when do we have free time yeah
so so Mr Ripple um make sure I don't
make a mistake with this please um but I
think uh Tuesday the 4th we don't have
anything scheduled yet for division
three that's correct I think you only
have Monday afternoon at this point okay
do are there other meetings that you're
trying to arrange with the Department
that would just haven't been settled yet
no no as as far as I know there won't be
any other uh presentations from the
Department until the governor's budget
comes out unless you or the committee
decide that you'd like others we we
added back potentially another visit by
it okay and and I can set up a separate
date for that uh but that as of now that
would be the only one okay and and there
might be a contract review we should
brainstorm that okay so so with that uh
representative walner I I can nominate
the fourth or or the 5ifth of
February what do you
think I actually think the fifth might
work better okay the only thing I got
going on is in the morning I want to
talk about rights of conscious for
medical professionals but but I got all
after 11:00 uh and this is in Manchester
right yes okay on Hanover Street so uh a
representative seaworth uh thank you Mr
chairman I recall listening to uh the
Waypoint people talk y um that they said
we welcome you anytime after and they
gave a date and I don't remember that
date at all the fifth was the date what
the fifth the fifth so we want to make
sure we don't go when they told
literally did they say after the fth or
fifth or after fifth or after I think
that's so let's let's you want to try
coordinating us for the fifth yeah I
will definitely and then Mr Ripple
should I submit a speaker request
because we're all going to be traveling
on a site visit and there because some
people may want to get mileage
reimbursement like representative
Stringham he doesn't have any money and
he comes from the North Country so so
that's a long drive for him uh that's up
to you I'm honestly not sure how that
process works so if it's it's something
You' think you'd like to do on behalf of
the members I'll check with the
speaker's office I when I when I we went
to glencliffe I found out after the fact
if I had told the speaker reimbursement
for mileage would have been easy and
obvious but I didn't so I see okay that
sounds like a good idea then oh
okay all right so morning afternoon I
I'd prefer afternoon okay so I will
notify them that we would come in what
time in the afternoon I'm I'm flexible
I'm wide open so at this point I would
listen to what works for them is did you
have more to say or something to say
well it's just I have a build to
introduce both one in the morning and
one in the afternoon but what what's
your introduction in the afternoon what
is it it's at one
o'clock so could we meet at ask them if
we could meet them at 3: a in the
afternoon or is that too late we
actually have a commitment at 3 o oh
yeah we do yes do you okay do you have
an alternative to somebody else to
introduce your one o00 bill
representative string 11 o' about 11 no
but maybe we can we can possibly but uh
maybe we can arrange uh two visits like
we did for um the cunu Youth Detention
Center last term okay so representative
walner I I could I could Bay down there
at 11:00 or thereafter okay okay I'll
organize it for 11:00 and make sure that
everyone gets
directions and probably you need to
we'll let us know if you're going to
come we'll send that an we'll send an
email to everyone on the division and
hopefully I'll know whether or not
people could submit for
mileage okay don't count on
it but I'll ask all right so that that's
that and I think think we're done with
our own internal
administrivia so if the department would
like to come up and start talking dcyf
topics okay begin so good afternoon
everyone again my name is Trish Tilly I
am an associate commissioner here at the
Department of Health and Human Services
and given your conversation you just had
about scheduling we have failed to tell
you um I realized that I should have
told you right before the meeting that
Chris santanello associate commissioner
santanello was also supposed to be
joining me today she is home with flu
some sort of illness and so we will not
be talking about um developmental
disabilities and healthy aging so so
we'll look to you to see if we want to
reschedule that for another time tack it
to something else so I would say yes and
and um so Mr Ripple and I think Mr White
have been working on scheduling so let's
just uh reschedule those two great and
if it if it tied up with it or or
contracts or whatever else that that's
fine great thank you so I we appreciate
your um flexibility in that so the good
news is that hopefully I will only take
one hour of your time today so that's
even better you get outside and enjoy
this gorgeous day outside so that's a
small gift that I have and we also are
giving you the gift of not having germs
in this room so that's also important um
I hope all of you have had your flu shot
or um any other things that you would
like to consider around that so what am
I going to do for this next hour I am
going to focus on three things I am
going to focus on our children's
Behavioral Health System I'm going to
focus a bit on DCF our division for
children Youth and Family
specifically as that relates to
residential care and um YDC or the
sununu youth services as we have it
right now and the new build in YDC and
then I'm going to talk a little bit
about the adult mental health system so
those are going to that's the universe
of the work that um I'm going to present
right now always happy to take other
questions as we move forward you have a
slide deck in front of you that you can
follow along if you would like there is
also another document in front of you um
that has some numbers on it it says 18
2122 this is in response to
representative Daniels had asked a
question around eligibility it's not a
very straightforward answer so I thought
it would be easier if we put it on paper
for you so all right so let's jump into
our presentation so on slide two you're
going to see the slide if you'll recall
that we talked about on Monday um one of
the things that I love the most about
working at the department of the health
and human services in New Hampshire is
the fact that we have the opportunity to
tie together so many of the services
that impact your families impact your
constituents and do it in a thoughtful
strategic way our road map has
identified our strategies and we're able
to think about how kids adults older
adults people who need specialized
Services how do all those systems work
together instead of just in isolation
and we do that you know specifically for
today our plan was to talk about kids
and talk about older adults and talk
about some of those adults who need
those specializ Services we'll do a
little shift and really just focus on
the kiddos and um the adult mental
health system but I'd love to have you
keep that in mind that that's really one
of the benefits of being what is often
called a super agency a very large
agency that has large breath and depth
within it is that we have an opportunity
to strategize think and instead of
working on individual projects really
thinking of them as a whole and their
crosscutting nature you know all the way
from public health which many of you
know is my my first work that I did that
really thinks about the entire
population and then as we think about
the other programs in the department
that focus on some more vulnerable
groups that need added attention
Children and Youth who have been abused
or neglected adults and children who
have developmental disabilities adults
who might have mental health or
behavioral health concerns that's the
universe that we work in and that's
where I think it is most exciting where
we have opportunities um when we always
have limited resources to make the best
use of what we have and knit things
together so they make it sense in the
community and makes things easier in the
community so let's jump in and start
talking about
kids
yes I want I want to contextualize this
for myself and and for some of the newer
folks um there there have been talks
over the last two or three or four years
of of possibly uh
subdividing um uh DHHS into at least two
distinct groups and what I think I just
heard you say uh uh could be
repurposed for the point of
understanding that you perceive value
and the Synergy of having a the current
whole in intact DHHS
and that we could be thinking of your
statement as as as sort of food for
thought when people do come around
talking about the separation of the
department that is correct that's a
great summary thank you sir okay all
right I I don't know that everyone knew
that this is sort of the background and
and even beyond that background it just
makes sense to me so whether or not
there's conversations happening in other
rooms in this in the legislative office
building around the what's the right
size or what's the right constellation
of services what I find Value in right
now is the ability to have all of these
programs under one leadership that has
the ability to see the whole picture so
either way it's important for some of
the legislative conversations but it's
also just important for the work that we
do every day regardless of what goes on
here all right thank you sure so I think
you'll see that same theme on slide four
as we flip there which is really around
this integrated approach to serving
youth so again today's plan was to focus
us on um DCF our division for children
youth and families our child welfare and
Juvenile Justice program our division
for Behavioral Health and our division
for long-term supports and services
without associate commissioner
santanello here today we're going to put
that part on hold and really focus on
the middle I I wanted to present this
though to know that again these things
don't happen in isolation um we have
work that happens in our division of
Public Health Services which is
preventative in nature we have work in
our division for economic services that
really provides the concrete supports
that families need to stay intact and
working together those are on the side
for today but it's critical to think
about each of those steps as making sure
that we're supporting Children and Youth
in the state and then finally across the
bottom you're going to see Medicaid and
we have that here there because we know
that Medicaid is a funer of many of the
specific Clinical Services that might be
needed whether it's in the division for
children youth and families or the
division for Behavioral Health or you
know Primary Care out in the community
that makes kids well and whole but we
need all of those things to be working
together um and we really need to
continue to integrate them across the
way so um we can flip over to thinking a
little bit more about um the behavioral
health needs of kids so what we know
right now um is that four out of 10 New
Hampshire High School students have have
identified as feeling sad or hopeless
that's 40 almost 40% of our kids in
addition we had we know that about one
out of five kids youth High School age
youth in New Hampshire have considered
suicide in the past year that's really
an extraordinary number to me if I if
you were all high school students up
there think about what one and five
would look like around your table and I
think that's really startling and it
highlights the need that we have seen
not only here in New Hampshire but
throughout the country around this real
elevation of the need to address
Children's Mental Health um across the
Spectrum within the context of their
families um and so that's what our
children's Behavioral Health System Of
Care seeks to do it seeks to work hand
inand with families to make sure that we
get the right K the right services for
the right kids at the right time as we
move forward you know the issue is
ubiquitous across all of our um across
our entire state it is certainly I am
sure each of you can think right now
that you may have a family member um
that has a child that is has some mental
health conditions or has some concerns
around their behavioral health certainly
your constituents do and we are here to
try and help alleviate that and make
that make the process easier for getting
the care that kids need so as you go to
slide six right now there's this is just
I'm sorry I I love your presentation
I'll never remember all the questions as
as um I see the the source of this data
is our um youth risk behavior
surveillance system uh and I see it's
for New Hampshire yes um do you think
this is um significantly different from
Maine or Vermont or Massachusetts are we
kind of consistent as a four state area
we are so I can't ask I don't know the
numbers off the top of my head but I can
tell you what I generally think and I
can certainly follow up with the exact
numbers for you this has been an issue
through the pandemic many of us heard in
2021 and in 2023 the increase of the
need around children's Behavioral Health
the good it really peaked in 21 during
the middle of the pandemic it inched
down just a little bit in 2023 and this
was consistent around the country New
Hampshire tends to report some of these
things higher than other states but I
can't tell you if it's significantly
different okay and just so you know I'm
I'm I'm I'm more interested in gen in
general en how uh our information
correlates with the other states this
just was an example where I could ask
the question but I'm I'm not interested
really in in this one point sure but
just sort of the general uh uh
comparable I and I would say that
nationally children's behavioral health
concerns are on the rise that's where I
would end that and similarly in the New
England area all right thank you you're
welcome so we we look at slide six
may I ask a follow-up question yours so
the the trend line
preco versus now easing into a post
postco uh period what did that look like
where you say four out of 10 was what
was that number pre-co so it was
probably closer to three out of 10 you
know like it was three or less in the
30s to 20s again I can get that data for
you later on and look at that trend line
it peaked up in 2021 it has slid down a
little bit in 2023 and currently we're
cap we capture this data every 2 years
we're in the middle of capturing it for
2025 now thank you thank you thank you
great so slide six a little visual here
so really describes what are we doing
about this what are we doing about this
concern that we have in our communities
and so we have put together um and when
I say we I really mean the general court
as well as the Department of Health and
Human Services has put together a suite
of interventions and legislation policy
and importantly financial investments
this is the the fiscal committee to
understand that um to address this
problem from many different angles so
starting over 10 years ago now you know
back in 2012 we the department received
some federal funding to start thinking
about what would a system of care look
like for children in New Hampshire so
again not Individual Services thought
about in you know nice discreet little
buckets but really how do we think about
this in a systemic way so we started
that planning back in
2012 we added the department of Ed to
that work we added different components
by 2019 we developed the Department's um
10-year mental health plan that was the
first time we had ever included children
in a mental health plan so up you know
less than 10 years ago is the first time
that that state had ever really
considered that kids might be an
important play in there and then from
then you'll see a suite of additional
legislation really creating this system
of care and importantly in here and I
think one of the critical elements as we
think about the other parts of my
presentation later on around YDC and
Juvenile Justice we made an important
distinction in 2022 in the middle of the
pandemic that we needed to transform our
Juvenile Justice work and that's
critically important because what we
were seeing was kids with behavioral
health issues Landing in essentially a
law enforcement pun punitive system
rather than getting the care that they
need and so that's to me just a
highlight as we go on and we have done
some extraordinary work that I can talk
a little bit more about later on around
rethinking the way we think about
Juvenile Justice and making sure that
we're supporting kids and not just
putting them into a secure facility on
the first blush the first interaction
with law enforcement it really changes
the way that we do work and I will also
note that it is also often times less
expensive to address those issues early
on we've um had some additional um
legislation even last year again
thinking about how we strengthen this um
this system of care so if we go to the
next slide which is slide seven this is
a you you said you only were going to
take an hour yeah I move so with me it's
going to be like two hours because this
is so good um HP 1573 and
sb47 I I don't recall the numbers I just
recall the the the legislative
discussion around this um there was a
fairly significant uh recommended
increase to um the amount of inspections
and followup related to outof State
placements yes and and I know know that
the policy committee and the finance
committee had different views and then
it went uh off into Committee of
conference stuff and I think I lost
track of it so so what would be nice is
not today but if whoever understands
what our commitment is stat from a
statutory perspective around the out of
state um inspections and Audits and
everything I i' I'd like to just be
reminded and that could be a phone call
or something happy to do that the short
answer is we are putting boots on the
ground eyes and ears into residential um
systems and providing more quality
oversight there's a financial component
that when you send people on airplanes
when you go driving around New Hampshire
to those residential places that costs
money of our state to do that so of our
state employees so we that was the
investment that was made by the general
court to say it is important to us to
put eyes and ears in those facilities
and then we're working closely with the
office of the child advocate to make
sure we're asking the right questions so
that's the short version but I can give
you a longer version so we're going to
probably have to revisit that in this
budget cycle so maybe maybe instead of
over the phone we probably need to
arrange like a a a 20 30 minute uh
presentation on that particular subject
happy to do that could could you add
that to the the to to-do list Mr Ripple
okay and because that's going to involve
numbers um we probably have to do it
after the Governor's budget is released
okay than thank you yeah absolutely so
um I'm trying to do my best to keep you
out of here in an hour but no you're
great you're great you're you're you're
you're making us smarter you're giving
us information I need for sure so so
let's just keep we'll keep going all
right all right so as you switch to
slide seven this is what we often show
as the Children's behavor Health System
Of Care framework it's a circle it's got
these little pies it's got tears we love
this in ocracy we love making little
little figures for you that say tier one
tier two but I think it's really helpful
for you to understand that um this
system of care while we often think
about tier five tier four very expensive
High need acute care psychiatric care
Residential Treatment the entire system
is predicated on thinking about those
earlier tiar as well making sure that um
kids in families every you know every
one of our kids kids have the sort of
Assessments and screening and treatment
that they get within weal child visits
with their families um making sure that
there are community-based services that
are close to home easy to access for
families to engage in and then you start
inching up into some of the more
intensive need Services the service
array includes a lot of things it
includes those you know again going for
your well baby's visit just to make sure
your child's well child visit just to
make sure things are going okay all the
way up to intensive crisis response and
stabilization Soup To Nuts as we flip
over though to slide eight I think one
of the ways I've been thinking about it
while I love that Circle that clearly
defines each of those tears and that
they they go around each other and we've
got rapid response when there's a crisis
for me what it highlights is that to
often we have spent most of our
resources and a great deal of our time
thinking about those high cost areas
those incred incredibly important acute
need services that are out of home and
in residential and we have spent less
time and energy focusing on the lower
intensity services that we would hope
could actually reduce the number of kids
that ultimately need those High acute
Services we are never going to get that
number to zero there are always going to
be children for whatever reason that may
have a condition a me a medical
condition that may need them that may
lead them or may more likely lead them
to need those Services we also have
youth that experience great trauma as
well and so that may you know exacerbate
their need for those higher Acuity
services but I do think firmly believe
we have an opportunity to um and my my
colleagues hate when I say this walk
into you gum at the same time here we
need to think about the preventative
stuff building early making sure that
we've got strong supports as well as
making sure that we're have the best
highest quality of care for those who
need the most intensive services and so
that's what this is really looking at is
this flip-flop of the of the pyramid we
spent a lot of money and a lot of time
thinking about those relatively few
number of Youth and not as much money
and time thinking of ensuring that we've
got the community- Based Services that
kind of keep kiddos out of that higher
need and so I like to think about it as
the way in that triangle is how can we
get closer to that knowing that the piie
is unlikely to get bigger you know the
amount of money is unlikely to get
bigger certainly in a budget season like
this and so how do we use what we have
to sort of move in there it's
aspirational but it is something I think
is worth disc to thinking
about um I'll go to representative wner
here in a second I I I think I think um
paradoxically we may be a uh in in some
ways a victim of our own success uh as a
state we have an extremely low per
capita uh number of kids in um
Residential Services uh we we're like
first or second I think depending on
what I remember from Mr ribson uh uh
commentary and so so I I although I love
the theory of of flipping this and
investing more in lower intensity Serv
Services aren't we ar aren't we going to
be going out and strictly on Theory uh
we don't really have any other states to
go look at to see what their experience
was or or or do we have other states
there are other states that have done
this work New Jersey is a great example
if anyone remembers director ribson he
would always start every sentence with
back in New Jersey um and but there are
places like New Jersey other states
we're actually you know you're skipping
to the end you've already read to the
middle of my presentation we're actually
involved in an assessment right now to
look at some of those other states to
see um what can be we can transfer to
New Hampshire okay I I'm totally
supportive of the theory I'm just
curious about our ability to leverage
the experience of others and it sounds
like we can that is my hope okay
representative
walner thank you that was sort of where
I was going I wanted to know if at some
point during the next few weeks when
we'll spend a lot of time together
probably you'll talk about what kinds of
preventive programs and you know how do
you how do you develop those do we have
models we can copy and really really
telling us about the programs yes yes I
won't have time to do that today but I
think that's a great question and I'll
I'll preface that by saying one of the
great things when um you know director
um ribson was here he brought a lot of
those community-based services to the
dcyf work and um what we're trying to
understand now the work that we have
today is really understand which one of
those makes the biggest difference you
know we brought a great uh menu that
we're selecting from and we have a
couple years under our belt to
understand what's working and what isn't
working we also can look to the National
evidence as well we can look to things
like our home visiting programs that are
completely primary prevention and we
know that some programs are better than
other programs according to the evidence
you know from National Data so things
like our Healthy Families America
program is an incredibly strong
evidence-based program about keeping
kids out of the child welfare system by
supporting moms and their babies early
on we can keep them out and we've added
on to that even now a special cohort
around um home visiting that's connected
with DCF for families who may have
already dipped their toe a little bit
into the DCF system and we don't want
them to go any farther thank you
so if we switch over to um slide nine
how do we pay for this you know this is
a great question and I appreciate the
the challenge that is in front of all of
us that's in front of you all that's in
front of us at the department knowing
that we have fewer resources we have
been flush over the past few years we've
had an influx of federal dollars to be
able to test new things um I would never
want another pandemic but that was one
of the only Silver Linings that it came
with was an opportunity to have some
additional federal funds to our
advantage um and so it's enable us to
get things some things stood up
including within our children's system
of care and if we think about this model
right here um what I would love for you
to take away from this is the fact that
there's no One Singular funding source
for for almost anything we think about
our community mental health centers
where kids with serious emotional um
issues can get care we we use both
Federal and general funds we have funds
that are budgeted within our division
for Behavioral Health that are General
funds we also have operational funds
through Medicaid same thing with our
Care Management entities which is one of
those strategies that we brought in a
few years ago to address the needs and
coordination of those very uh of those
kids with other incredibly complex needs
we put in federal and general funds to
make that work we think about
Residential Treatment this is a place
where some of the most complex Finance
happens because we have to piece
together a number of different funding
sources sometimes pieces of it can be
paid for with Medicaid sometimes it
can't it depends on the child you might
be able to use a little tanif sometimes
you can't if the child is in residential
care and and they need to have their
educational needs met the school
district may also throw in a little bit
and so this is one of the most
complicated pieces for luckily a very
small number of of kids um but it's
where we're putting everything into the
pie and trying to make um in trying to
make our dollars uh be Ive and also
everyone has a little bit of skin in the
game um and then of course our other
community based providers are sometimes
you know where it is appropriate we can
use Medicaid for operational work
sometimes that's not appropriate because
it's not a medical condition um and
that's where we also use a mix of
federal and general funds so as we move
through um I think it's important and I
I feel a little bit like I'm on repeat
on this but how do we measure the
success on this and the first thing we
need to realize is that 95% of our kids
are served in community- based settings
we talk a lot historically and and
certainly over the past couple sessions
here at the legislature we've
appropriately talked a lot about
residential care we have some things
that we needed to fix um but really
where we can get the most bang for our
buck is ensuring that those kids that
are in communitybased settings are
getting the appropriate care that they
need so that things don't escalate and
so that means that we have work that we
do around quality assurance with our
contractors we have work to make sure
that they are um that there's Fidelity
to some of those evidence-based
standards both clinical as well as some
of the programs like home visiting so we
make sure that folks are you know that
there's some there's some um science
behind the work that we do and that
they're working closely uh and they're
have Fidelity to those models but to me
the most important thing on this list is
looking at the Improvement in youth
functioning and so we have done this
one-on-one with kids a lot you know we
have a standardized assessment tool
that's something we've put in over the
past few years so we can actually
measure how well the kids are doing over
time we use the same tool over time and
you can see if kids are getting better
or kids are not getting better that's
really important to me one of the things
that I would love to do over the next
few years is to have further investment
in our data and our analytics ability to
actually think about that more on a
population level so kids receiving these
type of services are they getting better
as opposed to maybe kids receiving these
type of services that's really
complicated to do um but it's the sort
of work that we need to Endeavor upon
over the next few years to get to a
different level knowing that our pie is
never going to get is not going to get
bigger anytime in the in the near term
so are we are we promoting the right
things kids are all different they
respond to different things it won't be
a perfect algorithm them you're always
going to have to address individual
needs but I think we can be better
informed as we look at the Improvement
in you functioning it's something we
manage right now again on a case-by Case
basis but I think there's an opportunity
moving forward to think about the data
yes okay I I just want to understand
this 95% of Youth are served in the
communitybased settings what it's hard
for me to imagine a a subset of the
population that's actually getting
Services I I have to think of the kids
that are in our communities a majority
of them are getting no Services correct
they're go they are unserved correct
this the way this is written implies
that 95% of all kids in a community are
are getting some sort of service well I
I appreciate that and it is why it's
labeled at the top around how do we
measure success for children's
Behavioral Health so for the shock value
alone I put this larger number but it is
more nuanced you're correct of the
children receiving be children's
Behavioral Health Services 95% of those
are receiving communitybased Services
could you Hazard a guess on what
percentage of kids in communities are
just unserved I don't know that number
right now I could I probably can talk to
people just think about it I I don't
know if you need to research it but I
I'd be sort of curious yeah yeah okay
thank you and and it's also that's also
hard to answer because if you think
about that those tears that I had quite
frankly every kid should be getting
screened and assessed by their primary
care doctor so you would hope that at
some point that's everyone we bring our
kids to the doctor they say hey how you
doing th those are things that every
that's a population expectation okay a
represent prce thank you Mr chairman for
and thank you for taking my question um
do you have any studies I'm really big
on cost benefit analysis sure we know
what the cost is on these programs
we know the number of youths that are
being served by them and we
know the
benefits but I would like to quantify
those benefits with the dollar side do
you have any of that information so I I
can't rattle it off the top of my head
but I know that certain of our programs
this is why we we focus on these
evidencebased programs because often
times there were those sort of return on
investment studies whether it's a cost
benefit to say if you invest in this
program you're less likely to pay out
later on and oftentimes it's not within
the same system so especially with
children um who have experienced trauma
or children in our dcyf system we know
that um there's often a a direction that
many of them enter the correctional
system if their needs are not met and so
or even as we think about home visiting
services for babies there are long-term
studies that say if you provide these
early Childhood Services they're less
likely to enter into those costly um
Correctional settings or even in school
have the sort of um special ed
requirements that other kids have so
individual programs have that data could
I um get a copy of that inform we'll put
something together make it together
because I think it's very important when
we're talking about programs and and
whether or not they're advantageous or
cost effective absolutely thank you and
and I think one of the struggles that we
have um as a government agency and and
you all have every year is that often
those savings aren't realized in two
years that those are longterm life
course savings and so that's difficult
to budget for or it's it's complicated
to budget for I don't know that it's
difficult but it is it adds a
complication because oftentimes you're
not saving money
tomorrow thank
you I I I I'm I'm dwelling on on the on
the implication of page 10 here still
and
uh and I'm it it seems to me that
there's some percentage of our youth
population that are so emotionally and
mentally healthy that they don't really
come into our system correct right
correct and what are we doing to
understand the kids that don't need any
Services because we need to do more of
that you know what um you are speaking
my language right now because that's
what in in this world we call protective
factors kids who have protective factors
around them and don't end up you know
that they have resiliency and protective
factors and we know some of those things
we know that having you know their
financial needs met if you've got house
stable housing if you have food to eat
all of those things are protective
factors um and then there's also other
things that are harder to quantify
around the stability of a family again
not all kids even the kids in you know
the most idelic Beaver to you know Leave
it to Beaver family there are going to
be kids that for whatever reason have
needs that need to be met but I think we
do know that there are the the supports
that we need is you know Str connections
to community connections to um having a
caring adult in your life that's one of
the main things right there as simple
and complicated as that
is all right this and this isn't as much
to ask you for an an answer but just to
drop a a thing that I've been thinking
about for a few months and that is
I'm I'm I'm I'm just generally concerned
if the programs that we're setting up
have the right incentives in them uh and
and so there there is an incentive I
think for uh individuals to go out and
seek care and stay in a care environment
and and get whatever benefits you know
um they can through um a care
environment so at an individual level
there's somewhat of an incentive build
in to go seek
services and then I think also from the
program management perspective sometimes
we end up with situations where um uh
the people that work for uh the state uh
through contract or through employment
they have an incentive I think sometimes
to um to to to to build the program to
to get as many numbers as they can and
and so it makes me wonder what kind of
incentive system uh we might need
uh or if there is a need to encourage
our our own team to be actively seeking
ways to get people out of
programs thank you um you know I would
certainly suggest that no one wants kids
to not be well I I I right but I'm I'm
I'm I'm also just worried about the the
the our team our team needs an incentive
to actively try to achieve success
because I you know I used to be in the
military I saw how bureaucracy can work
if you want your program to do well if
you want to do well you try to grow your
program and and there aren't natural
incentives built into the system to have
people try to uh unwind their program
the only time I've seen that actually is
what Medicaid was doing to get people uh
postco off that's a rare instance so I
don't know that there's an answer to it
I just thought I would share with you
one of my my my background creeping
concerns about are incentive systems
built to encourage everyone to be
working towards the same objective which
I hope is to have healthy people who
don't need programs correct I I would
agree with you in that you know and I
think we have examples where you know we
have seen that data work our Juvenile
Justice transformation is probably one
of the best examples we no longer have
an incentive to get as many kids in syc
as possible I don't know that there ever
was an incentive but we're now really
the movement is let's make that number
as small as
possible I just had a comment on that I
first want to sorry I want to thank you
Miss Tilly for I love the triangle and I
love the philosophy behind it in
investing in these programs that bring
protective factors to children and and
stopping it at the at the base level um
um and I just wanted to say that the
visual I think is very helpful and if we
can find those ways we're not looking to
grow the bureaucracy around the top part
of the triangle however looking how we
can wrap around those people at the
bottom to make sure and and it allows us
to change the focus of the department to
Wellness as opposed to having to provide
that Urgent Care um I think is a is a a
good goal for all of of us to have thank
you so that was a comment not a question
back so we can flip back to that tippy
top of the the um of the pyramid again
on slide 11 so this is uh information
that we often share at Children's
oversight committee so one of the many
ways that we have accountability to our
program specific Al around the division
for children youth and families and our
division for Behavioral Health is we
have a children's oversight committee um
Senator Carson and Senator Whitley had
co-chaired that in the past it will be
reestablished in in February 21st for
this time and this is a slide that we
present to them every every time we meet
whether it's monthly or or every other
month is just sort of the understanding
again around Residential Care given the
focus of the um impact to kids as well
as the financial impact of residential
care and here's where you can see we've
got 349 kids this was back in um I think
this was early early January data um yes
January 7th we pulled this up we had 349
kids the vast majority of those kids are
here in New Hampshire 262 of those 349
they're here and then the next group is
a few more are in New England especially
because we try and keep them close to
home close to the people who care about
them close to the people who love them
often times if you live in Nashville
that's in MA that's in Massachusetts
that's not way up North and so we think
about New England care as keeping folks
close to home just given the small size
of our New England states and then you
can see this small number that we always
hope for it to be smaller that might of
individuals who might need care outside
of New England and that's because those
kids have such incredibly complex needs
um and may have been served already and
likely have been already served in New
Hampshire or New England and their their
um need for specialization exists that
we need to find somewhere else in the
country that's a good fit for them but
what we do is the minute folks are leave
you know we've got a youth who needs to
go to Florida for care we're working
right away to figure out how do you get
them back home you know and and that's
been a cultural shift um in the work
that we do uh because in some ways we're
often just happy to have a place where
they're thriving happy to have a place
that they're getting the care that they
need and our staff can you know take
especially for the kids that are in DCF
our staff can take a break a breath
because they know they're safe and
they're cared for but we've really
pushed on our practice and our culture
to say oh you know let's figure out what
the pathway is to coming back home
what's the pathway to eventually having
this youth if not live with their own
biological family with kin with Foster
family that's ready to meet their needs
so this this is just a uh this uh slide
is really just an example of the
complexity of that care and the fact
that we are working on it with each
individual those kids especially that
are in our um division for children
Youth and Family system to make sure
that they're getting the care that they
need that they're safe and that we're
thinking about ways to get them back
home in whatever home means for them so
moving on to the next slide so where are
we going next I think you know as we've
described that triangle is really the
visual in my mind is flipping that
triangle um representative Edwards had
asked are you thinking about other
models and the answer is absolutely 100%
we're in the middle of working on an
assessment with some national experts
who know the children's system of care
work that's happening all around the
country they interviewed a cast of
thousands in New Hampshire they
interviewed providers they interviewed
families they interviewed bureaucrats
like me to say what's working and what's
not working in our current system of
care how can we continually assess it
and really focus on what our progress
needs to be what are our next steps
final report is due in March we're very
excited about it we've seen some
previews of that work um and none of it
is particularly um surprising although
you can flip to the to the next page on
13 you know some of these These are the
themes that we're seeing right now and
again this comes from the providers in
the community from families who've
experienced it youth who've had lived
experience these are some of the themes
we're thinking about is around again how
do we not only have those Prevention
Services but how do we align them how do
we know we're moving towards the same
thing towards the same goal especially
if you think back about the the fact
that we have you know activities across
the Department Child Care is a
protective Factor that's a great example
that's not within the division of
Behavioral Health but it's critical um
component to making sure kids are
healthy how do we centralize a place to
call um we have often had what we call a
no wrong door policy um and um but
sometimes that's too diffuse for people
and so we need to think about both how
we Market it and how we structure how do
we know where to to call when we need
help and then we just have to scale The
Helpful Services strengthen those
supports to stay home coordinate expert
care and then you know the piece that
always i' like to stay up working on is
how do we measure that progress how do
we know that what we're doing works at
each of those levels so I'm going to
move into our division for children
youth and families now if if with
without any more questions so a critical
comp you know you think about the
division for Behavioral Health and the
children's system of care that's all
kids um with specific focus on kids on
Medicaid and kids that are in dcyf and
then we think about our dcyf system um I
I've been lucky to be working more
closely with DCF for the past year
although I had spent my previous life in
public health working with DCF a lot
especially around the Prevention
Services or the prevent those those
areas around young children in
particular and I have always been struck
by this ntion this notion that we truly
are all in this together dcyf is not
something that just happens over in a
corner it really is all of our jobs in
the community to make sure kids are safe
um primarily it's the reason why all of
us are mandated reporters um we all want
Safe Kids we all want strong families we
all want stable communities in that way
we have done some tremendous work um DCF
unfortunately as you all know has been
in the spotlight for quite some time um
and I have been so impressed with the
way in which our our current director
Marie nuned has gathered the troops
focused on high quality practice making
sure what we're doing um is the right
sort of work we should be doing it is an
alignment with our policies and our
procedure and most importantly we're
keeping Kids Safe um we've made a number
of improvements as we focused on focused
on this both in the child protection
space as well as Juvenile Justice and
you know I'd be thrilled to stay here
and talk for hours about the work that's
happening here it's really quite
extraordinary one of the cultural shifts
that you see and and has been part of
this entire story is around serving
youth at home and youth belong to F
along with families and we know that
that's not always the family of origin
but that can be a me a family member a
kinship is what we call it in that in
that space um and it can also be
something that we call fictive Kin which
is a a word that sounds a little clunky
but that could be the coach that could
be someone who's vetted in their
communities a friend to the family who
we that is safe and really the right
place where that child can Thrive rather
than a historical perspective of moving
kids always into foster care or worse
yet Residential Care and so this shift
this shift and really further focus in
this area I think is going to make some
fundamental changes over the ne over the
next few years for the first time now we
have more kids in kinship placements
again where they're not safe to be with
their family of origin but but there's
someone in their lives there's family in
their lives that they are safe with and
so we're making sure to facilitate that
and strengthen those those relationships
so that it's easier for that to happen
in additionally as we look at um our
priorities you're going to see that
you're going to see this focus of you
know the right services at the right
time you're going to see that family
engagement really is the heart of dcyf
and back to the and to the bottom of
there you're going to see some metrics
and that's the work that we're doing to
sort of measure how well we're doing so
we know that we are accountable not only
to bodies like children's oversight to
you all at the general Council to our
governor's office we're accountable to a
lot of people they advisory groups that
were accountable and this is the way
that we're going to show you that that
we we mean business and we're we're
measuring what we're doing so we're
looking at reducing Residential
Treatment by 10% we're looking at incre
you know decreasing those vacant cpsws
you know we all know that we need to
have good case loads where child
protective workers can see all the kids
that they're supposed to see and have
eyes and ears on them to in order to
keep them safe we want to make sure that
kids are served in their own homes um
you know as much as possible again
keeping a family intact where it's
possible and wrapping services around
them whether it's the Behavioral Health
Services for Mom and Dad or the
Behavioral Health Services for the kids
to make sure that that's a safe
environment um we also you know we have
some real structure we need to do around
YDC we know where they we're going to
need to reduce the number of kids that
are served in the secure facility and
finally in order to make this happen in
order even to understand this data and
have this sort of the the watch the
metrics we are building a new um system
called Granite families a new data
system heard a little bit about with
Dave weeders yesterday we this is long
time in coming the data system we use
right now is from the 1990s it is woful
inadequate we need to have this data
system to do our work say say that it
system again it's called Granite
families we are moving from Bridges to
granate families thank you and it will
likely be at the council um soon soon I
I don't want to give a date but it's
soon so we have been working on it for a
number of years pulling this together
because the federal government is paying
for it the administration for children
youth and families each step along the
way they have to approve it um we have
our own rigorous standards here at it
for privacy and security and all of that
so it has taken some time for this
Behemoth system to get through those
processes but we have final approval
from our federal funders that our
contract makes sense and we're ready to
bring it to council soon
thank
you representative
Daniels thank you did you just say that
the federal government was paying they
have they pay a significant part of it
so what what happens when the federal
money runs
out you know um that that will we will
cross that bridge when we get to it
about whether we don't anticipate this
to be at a federal cut right now this is
not um in any of the executive orders
that we have seen from uh the Trump
Administration so we anticipate that the
federal government is going to honor its
commitment to keeping kids safe and our
our partnership there and I don't know
Nathan if you want to remind me if that
is a 100% federal or not I I would have
to go back and look at it but I think
what's important to recognize here is
that the federal funds are being used to
build the system so there will be
ongoing maintenance costs but the the
bulk of the cost are The Upfront
development of the new system and and
that'll be a one-time cost that we're
that's satisfied today I I I see Mr
weeders shifting in his seat did you did
you want to say something to that Mr
weers you you can just use a mic at the
here so the funding for Grant families
is using ACF funding it's a 50% match so
all the funding from ACF is usually a
50% match for the design development and
implementation as well as ongoing
maintenance of the system this is done
for all the states in the in the country
vastly unlikely that ACF would not fund
these type of solutions for the
different states throughout the
country sorry Administration for
Children and Families right so that
that's the feds the feds are going to
continue to pay 50% you think they have
they have given no inking of not
continuing that all right does that
answer your question representative
Daniels yeah I don't just don't know how
much confidence I have in uh an entity
that is trillion tens of trillions of
50% all right um thank you
thank you
to representa Mooney thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
foster parents how are you doing with
regards to uh the amount that are
available at this point and that leads
me to marketing I saw a very nice
bulletin board not long ago in
Manchester recruiting foster parents and
I'm curious as to how marketing is
determined uh to recruit and if that's
worked and what the criteria would be to
start a marketing campaign to recruit
more Foster parents thank you thank you
so much for asking that question um so
foster parents are really at the heart
as much as uh I've talked about in and
appropriately we want to make sure that
kids um have a first hit of getting U
matched with one of their family because
we know that that's good for them when
that can't happen we need foster parents
so important and so we need to support
them in a couple ways we need to pay
them appropriately and so one of the
things that we will all be thinking
about in this budget is the rates for
foster care and the rates for Foster
care are far less than the rates for
residential care Residential Care can
cost upwards from 300 almost $400 a day
up to $1,800 a day and rates for foster
care are in the 40s 50s 60s $ 70s $80 a
day so there it is a huge difference and
we know that kids are better cared for
at home we have staff dedicated to doing
that work with a foster uh care Outreach
and marketing we can always do better we
work really closely with organizations
um there's a foster parent organization
that we work hand inand with as well I
did one of the first things that I did
in my job when I took this um this
particular role was go up to the North
Country we did a phenomenal event to
really support and bring in foster
parents and But ultimately like all of
us for Mom and Dad to be home you know
someone to be home to be a foster parent
we have to support them with a rate that
makes sense one of the things that we
are considering in addition or more than
considering we're about to launch is a
an intensive um foster care rate for
those who are taking those children that
are the most complex again less than it
costs for residential care but the
notion that we know that some of those
um youth who've been languishing in
residential care really would be better
Su suited if they were home but we need
to support families so that they can
spend the time with that youth that's
needed so it's you know we always need
more
um and we can certainly do better around
marketing but we've put specific effort
and put in staff in place that that's
their whole
job to can you Hazard a a number at uh
capacity because I I heard in the
implied in the question is you know
where where are we at with our our
perception of our total need and versus
where we think we are with actual
capacity so I mean if you think about
the kids that are in those um especially
the mid-level of care and residential
care there those are opportunities where
all of those kids might be better suited
you know especially after a round of
treatment um in a residential program in
the community so we could use more you
know whether that's TW you know I Hazard
to say the exact number but I look at
that residential number as the place
where we don't have another place in the
community for those kids to be right now
um so we could just use more foster
parents so I'm a find I need a number at
some point we'll get you number even if
it's a range and it's it's
a disclaimed I I need a number uh
representative walner did you have a
question yes thank you so in addition to
the rate that we pay foster parents I
often hear from foster parents that
there are other things they need besides
just the rate they need maybe respit
they may need help with some
Transportation I mean they're all those
kinds of things also and when you
recruit new Foster families do they know
what they what other kinds of services
they can get um you know in the best
case scenario of course we want to make
you know we're recruiting we're trying
to give them the op the and we also um
connect them with other foster parents
because we all know peer-to-peer
learning and someone to call on the
phone or text is probably way better
than reaching out to the cpsw at DCF so
we're trying to pair that and really
wrap ourselves around those new Foster
families so that they can succeed that
also is um you know Con making sure that
we are consistent among our child
protective workers that they're really
having that relationship and um holding
space for those foster families so that
we can hear those concerns you at you
mentioned Transportation which is a huge
issue another budget constraint of ours
it has been many many years since we've
increased the rate that we pay our
transportation contractor and that's
something that we're going to you know
need to consider in a in an upcoming
budget is how do we pay for
transportation because kids need to go
to their doctor appointment or and
whatnot and if the family if the Foster
family can't do that then it becomes
incumbent on the child protective worker
to get that youth from point A to point
B we also want um youth to be in contact
with their own family with the hope of
reunification and again we need
Transportation um we use that that
Transportation um contractor you know
because we pay at such a limited rate
isn't always available to us and so
instead we end up paying more money for
a social worker to be The Driver as
opposed to paying the transportation
example you've used your hour I you're
going I know I I haven't even gotten to
the adults yet all right representative
that was a joke by the way
representative well thank you and this
won't take too long you've given us um
the cost ranges for the Residential Care
depending upon the need of the child the
the the range for foster care um and we
have kind of the the numbers on both of
those on the community base to you have
a number that you pay uh kin family
members to take um a child in need so
that's a complicated question sometimes
um depending on the relationship but
again there are associated with some of
those Guardians ships and we can get
back to you with that yeah and then um
um I'll let Nathan read it because I
can't read over his um sure so so there
there there's a variety of ranges for
foster care rates and um there's General
foster care for ages 0 through five and
then there's respit rates as well and
those daily rates range from a low of
$34 28 up to almost 50 or 6 $64 61
sense so this is the uh kin family care
right or is this the foster care um the
there's I I can provide the community
with a listing because there's there's a
there's a matrix of detail here that you
probably don't want me to narate but I
can certainly send that to you so you
can kind of see the complexity there um
so that the rate is spec is specific for
the particular case that would be very
helpful thank you thank you and and you
know to send it to Mr Ripple and he'll
help us distribute
it so if I fly through the rest did you
have a question representative Daniels
no great so as we looked to slide 16
again this is just showing the story
that I've told several times we have
fewer youth um in Juvenile Justice we
have this reduced Reliance on
residential care and uh specif and also
in Secure settings so you can see that
daily count of um ju Juvenile Justice
involved youth that number is going down
the total number of voluntary episodes
of treatment of Behavioral Health Care
is going up that the numbers are less
important is really just the the slope
of both of those um um graphs As you
move to slide 17 this is where we really
see it play out at the cuno Youth
Services Center um we've seen this
starts in the year 2000 goes to
2024 this radical um reduction in the
number of Youth that are we are being
served at the snoo Youth Services Center
where you had over a hundred kids in
there at a time and we're now down to
some days single digits often times
certainly um 15 or less is where we are
or 18 or less and that is where we're
moving towards with our new facility and
so if you can flip to page uh the next
slide on slide 18 this is just the
graphic of the new build that's being
built at Hamstead on the property of the
Hamstead hospital um we're very excited
about it ground has broken the tree
clearing began began back in November um
excavation started in early December um
and we're going to have the foundation
hopefully is going to get poured around
February 17th so that is moving ahead
the big machines are there things are
happening um in in Hamstead um the
smaller footprint we think is going to
be as a facility less expensive to run
the current uh cuno Youth Services
Center is an enormous C campus and has
the costs associated with being um a
building that was designed to serve over
a hundred youth when we're really
serving a smaller number so we will have
a smaller more efficient building um one
of the things I know representative
Edwards has always been interested in is
around the shared services that we might
get by being on the same campus next to
Hamstead hospital we had started doing
some of that analytic work um as we were
planning now with um Dartmouth taking
over and leasing the Hamstead hospital
um some of those assump
um need to be Revisited but it is built
into the contract that was passed at um
governor and Council and it is built
into the lease with Dartmouth that we
explore what some of those opportunities
are the um we are restarting those
conversations right now so I I can't
give you specifically what the what how
that will play out that is just in still
in development we anticipate that that
closing on that lease is going to happen
in February but it's certainly an
opportunity to um work more closely
together on that one
campus so um do we have a covered
Corridor connecting Hamstead and the new
facility um we are working towards that
I might ask uh again Dave weers he's
been the the clerk of the works on this
in some regards so of where we are with
the the collaboration Corridor as I
think it was called or or or culture
Corridor I better that I like that um
but that's really critical to the
success because not only um is that a a
physical sign of the relationship
between the two buildings but if you're
moving food and laundry back and forth
you actually need some cover right and
then I'll come to you next um
representative
torki um thank you for the question um
in regards to a covered walkway between
the two facilities we would still need
to find funding to do that so it is not
currently in the scope of work for the
build so so you know the word walkway is
is verboten we're talking corridors
or a corridor is and you still need M
money yes we do still need fund where
where are you requesting the money is it
in the budget is it a priority need is
it what is it it it's just what is it it
it currently is not in either a
prioritized need or in the budget
so you're not asking for
money we we currently do not have a
formal request in the agency budget that
was submitted back in August okay so if
you're not asking for money it's not
going to happen is what I'm I'm I'm
sorry I'm being simple so um pardon me
Marissa hen Deputy Commissioner so back
in November December we came to you all
um I believe actually former Governor
tunu actually attended the fiscal
committee um where some of the remaining
um uh recovery dollars arpa dollars were
uh redeployed toward this project um as
you know uh this project requires use of
arpa dollars and and or federal dollars
and cannot use General funds so um when
we went out to bid on the contract with
um with the with the construction firms
we had them scope out the work for that
um culture Corridor um as you've called
it so they're definitely it's it's we
are it's theoretically capable of being
um uh integrated into the contract the
challenge is under HB 49 um we C we
cannot use General funds toward this
build so that limits our ability to come
to you to ask for additional funding for
the
build all right we should take it
offline but yeah but so let's talk more
I think we you have been a a huge
advocate um representative Edwards and
uh we share as you and I have had many
conversations about the importance
symbolically practically efficiency wise
so we are do you know the new governor
is aware of the issue we are continuing
to keep her briefed on all aspects of
the construction um and so I think this
particular narrow pet peeve issue I
can't speak to her specific there's a
lot of details in this project including
about 30 ad alternate components this is
one of which so let's connect offline
about whether or not we we do that thank
thank you Dr hen uh representative
tki I'm not sure if this is going to be
addressed further down the right down
the road when we actually have numbers
in front of us and we talk about this
project in particular which is fine we
can talk about it then but I have a
memory of this fall perhaps a discussion
that there was an attempt to expand the
scope and the number of beds for the
facility and is that something that I
misunderstood or thank you so there were
a lot of conversations when this um
project went to governor and Council in
the fall um the the letter noted a a bed
count higher than what was expected of
the 12 bed the 12 youth census that we
were talking about so the the um
strategy is still the same our goal is
to have a facility that serves 12 youth
in order to do that you actually need
more physical beds than 12 beds so that
you need to have a place for isolation
for you know for illness you need to
have isolation you need to be able to
separate boys and girls in certain ways
so that that the phys the furniture
needs to be more than 12 but the intent
is to serve no more than 12 just so that
you can separate as needed okay so that
was just a problem in interpreting yes
the language thank you I I i' I'd add a
little more it's always been 12 is the
goal with a surge capacity of up to 18
and the ability to be flexible within
that uh for a little while there was
some bad miscommunication that led the
community to believe that we were going
to violate the 18 ceiling but that was
never the case that was just bad
communication so it it it it's 12
Baseline surge up to 18 is still the
plan and I'm glad I asked the question
so I can understand better yeah yeah no
no I'm glad you did yes and again lots
of miscommunications around things like
just physical furniture that it takes to
serve that number of Youth
representative Daniels
thank you um recently there was uh as we
all know something going on with
Dartmouth and an individual who needed a
kidney transplant and they refused them
and then they later uh revers their
position do we know with certainty that
Dartmouth Hitchcock will not turn away
uh individuals who are going to be
housed here if they have not been
vaccinated that would not be any um
practice that we would encourage it it
that has not come up at all it would not
be uh it is not within any of our
contracts it we would expect them let me
reframe that we would expect them to
serve all youth no matter whether they
were vaccinated or not so that's the
better way I say so while while you are
negotiating with with Dartmouth is there
going to be a clause in the contract
that says that you are you are to follow
all of the state laws I'm going to let
um uh Deputy Commissioner answer that
great but yes the answer is they will
follow all state laws great and just to
clarify so Dartmouth Health um with the
closing that is expected to take place
in a matter of days um Dartmouth health
is taking over the uh the operation and
administration of Hamstead hospital so I
just want to be clear about that while
that campus will be home to um uh in the
future to YDC once the Manchester campus
closes and while Dartmouth is an
important partner at YDC um what we're
talking about in terms of this public
private private partnership is a
psychiatric um impatient facility and
residential treatment uh Center and in
the lease um we have a number of
mechanisms to ensure uh to oversee that
facility but one of them is a
requirement to comply with all federal
state laws extensive um prohibitions
around discrimination and so we feel
confident that there will be um no
issues uh uh around what you're
describing and that will continue to
stay very involved as the um as the
entity that oversees Healthcare facility
licensing but also as the landlord and
the the owner of that um physical
facility thank Youk I I I'd like to
throw in another little piece to this
puzzle
um Mr Ripple is helping me I think with
an hb2 item that basically will require
the state to uh only contract with
hospitals that comply with the statute
around the patient Bill of Rights an a
component of the patient Bill of Rights
is is the vaccination issue so so the
Department's already on top of it and
I'm opening to put something into hb2 so
that uh that it'll just be routine that
when we contract that we contract with
the expectation that the patient Bill of
followed representative Mooney thank you
Mr chairman and thank you while I'm
thinking of it and while we're on the
topic of the new YDC facility as I
recall last term we appropriated a
rather
costly uh searching machine similar to
what you would see in a
airport yes just want to be sure that
that machine follows the construction
yes I can imagine it's quite large and
there's placement for it thank you thank
you all right thank you um slide 19 just
uh Lo looks a little bit about the
workforce and sort of again some of what
we anticipate what our current positions
are at YDC what we anticipate the new
this is a mix of both state positions
and contracted positions so this isn't a
full-time you know uh you know these
aren't all full-time positions that are
in the state they're noted some of them
are contracted some are there but really
around to this notion of what's it going
to take to run the new center they are
similar in number there are
opportunities again as we work with um
Dartmouth at Hamstead Hospital not at
YDC to see where we have some um further
opportunities for shared services I
noted at the top we have an unbudgeted
Vision which is a something that I know
that is near and dear to repres
representative Edward's heart around
thinking about security and so we have
not yet built that into our budget to
figure out how to do that um
understanding that our our pie is only
so big at this moment but here's what it
would take what we think is the number
anticipated to run the new facility
appropriately so so I just have the
comment that just be consistent over the
last three years or so the this still
makes it look like security is an
afterthought or a bolt-on this is first
and foremost a secure facility in which
we provide good clinical care and so
it's it's a it's a little disturbing to
see a security team listed here as an
add-on instead of an integrated element
of of the
team I I I think what's important to
understand is that we prepared our our
budget um almost 6 months ago and there
have been a lot of ongoing conversations
for some time there's been a team
looking at the transition and what the
new setup would look like there so when
we prepared our original budget we
didn't have those those specific issues
finalized and those are the issues that
we'll be working with with this
committee and others in the future on
yes and I just wanted to be transparent
that they're not in the budget right
now thank you so um I am looking at the
time and I'm looking to the chair should
adults I think everything you've said
has been useful and uh if you're
prepared to talk more about this slide
deck let's keep going all right thank
you so much so let's talk about adults
now in our community mental health
system just as sort of Baseline for
everyone we have a safety net of um 10
Community Mental Health centers around
the state they are designated in statute
as to the work that they provide or the
services they provide primarily for a
lowincome population for individuals who
are on Medicaid and individuals with
severe um mental health conditions and
so those are around um they provide case
management and medication all of the
resources that you could imagine that
those mental health uh the mental health
need to meet mental health needs within
our state um not only do we work with
the mental health centers themselves
we also have peer support agencies we
have Family mutual support we're really
building a system to make sure that we
can support individuals in their
Community the theme throughout for today
is really how can we keep people
Everyone kids adults home safe and cared
for within their community so that they
can be as productive as possible I'm
going to fly through a little of these
because I I know that we are a little
bit short on time um it's important to
know that we serve around 60,000 just
shy of 60,000 individuals a year through
the community mental health system so
that's a large number those are your
constituents who are being served um by
our cmhc's we have seen consistent
growth in that over time um and uh we
noted today this morning at fiscal um we
our department um dashboard looks a
little stagnant that's really only
because two of our larger um Community
Mental Health Systems are going through
an electronic health record conversion
they haven't sent us their numbers in
the way that we would hope as they're
going through that conversion but we
continue continue to see you know a
plateau of um and growth um in services
and and folks being served within those
communities representative Edwards noted
that um we it all went through the
Medicaid unwind at the end of the
pandemic that was particularly felt by
the Community Mental Health Centers a
number number of their in of the folks
that they treat had been on Medicaid
uninterrupted for a number of years
through the pandemic as the unwind
happened they were continuing to to
receive care there when they may no
longer have had Medicaid and so that has
had a financial impact on our community
mental health centers even though that
is happening and they have our community
mental health centers have been serving
all the individuals they need to serve
we have also done some great things
around real really building issues
around rapid response it's something
that I know that many of you have heard
of which is this notion of having a
you'll you'll hear themes to what we
were talking about with kids you know
someone to answer someone to respond and
somewhere to go this has been an
incredibly important addition to Our
Community Mental Health Services making
sure that we have um a place to answer
questions to um meet needs far away from
hospital emergency rooms when possible
so that we can meet those needs um in
the community and we can help folks get
stabilized there the growth in um rapid
response we've seen that continue to
grow since it was brought online in 2021
we continue to see that move forward and
have that centralized access point
really work it's one of the things that
we're proudest of um over the past
couple years in our mental health system
um if you flip to page uh to slide 26
this is another one of these big boxes
where it looks like I'm yelling at you
because I'm I really want to break this
point known um that eight out of 10 of
our community mental health centers
report operational losses right now um
they uh like our federally qualified
Health Centers um that do primary care
and traditional Medical Care our
community mental health um centers have
felt the sting of that Medicaid unwind
and the end of the pandemic um both the
federally qualified Health Centers and
the Community Mental Health Centers
receive some additional arpa funds um to
help support them as we were going
through these
transitions this slide is to note that
there are still they are still
experiencing some of those losses and
it's really from three big bucket areas
it's around uncompensated care it's
around the C the increasing cost of
Workforce as well as the availability of
Workforce and then overall the cost that
we all feel every day of heat and
keeping buildings running and keeping
the lights on all of those things have
contributed to those operational losses
the workforce in particular I know we've
been talking about Workforce for years
I'll just highlight again that it really
is twofold so if um it is harder to
bring staff on board it's more expensive
and it's harder to bring staff on board
and if they don't have the staff on
board they can't generate the income
through um Medicaid they can't get their
their income generation so it's a one to
punch if you can't have the staff there
you can't have the billable hours that
help with your um operational costs and
so um the CM we have been working
closely with the cmhc's after this $5
million um uh gr uh $5 million contract
from arpa money that was used to help
support them um for almost all of them
and we are working closely with them
monitoring their financials on a on a
quarterly basis representative Str
so do you anticipate that they're
covering operational losses from other
donations from the community or is this
a dying model without um a significant
change in the way that uh the
operational services are funded so part
of what we ask them to do is to do that
work amongst themselves to figure out
what the what they need to do in order
to sustain themselves with the current
model and we're looking for those
recommendations to come from them as
well that's incumbent on them and their
boards to figure out
thank you all right great so Community
Mental
Health did you have a question
representative priest yes I do thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question could you give us some examples
of what these Community Mental Health
Facilities are not able to do now
because of the lack of staff and the
lack of the billable hours to get thank
you for that question question so I
think some of them are still trying to
do everything they were doing before um
because you know they have patients that
need to be seen we have certainly had
conversations with some of the Community
Mental Health Centers as they think
about whether or not they can take all
comers it and whether or not we need to
suspend that we have often put a
suspension in hb2 language that they
would not have they could have a waiting
list if they needed to have a waiting
list in order to manage
that okay so they have a waiting list
now or they some may some May
okay and then the other piece that that
is another component of this is is an
overall model shift to something called
our certified community behavioral
health clinic and that's also a model
that is taking a little bit of time to
get started but it really looks at
integration of both physical and mental
health wellness and so we have been able
so three of the um Community Health
Mental Health Centers have had some
additional Federal funding to again
think about what the operational model
with that would be and how sustainable
it could be mooving as they sort of
change their structure to meet the um
declining need the declining resources
that are available to them okay thank
you great so at the heart so the
Community Mental Health Center is
incredibly important um part of our
fabric of our safety net you we cannot
function as a state in meeting the needs
of people with significant Mental Health
conditions without those Mental Health
Centers and one of the ways that they do
that is they play a critical role in
Mission zero so if you look at slide 27
you've heard us talk about this a lot it
is one of the Marquee um components of
our road map over the past couple years
which is to reduce to zero very
actionable the number of adults that are
waiting in an emergency hospital
emergency board room boarding waiting to
get access to acute care to get that to
zero I can report that we have met zero
on individual days it is we have not yet
been able to sustain ourselves at zero
this is an incredibly complex issue and
we have dedicated um we have worked
closely with our Hospital partners and
other Community Partners to address the
three big drivers around emergency room
boarding and that is what we Cally call
the front door um coordination and the
back door we need to get people in we
need to coordinate that flow we need to
be able to get people out of the
hospital emergency department into an
acute setting and then we also have to
be able to transition them out of that
hospital so other folks can get in and
to do that um you know we have these
sort of we've identified these six
things that we're working on that we
think are the real um levers that we can
pull to get that front door open to get
the right people in the right place and
then to get the back door open which is
to get folks back safely and what in
their community in a way that that is
sustainable and so that's looking at the
expansion of community behavioral health
clinics I just talked a new model of our
community mental health centers um
increasing opportunities for
community-based crisis stabilization we
just had the opportunity the
commissioner and I and others going up
to Plymouth to look at some of that work
around having a place to go um just to
get stabilized with peer support as well
as clinical support when things are just
feeling like they're escalating that's
incredibly important to keep people from
needing to go to the emergency
department care traffic control which is
that coordination which is centralizing
with all the hospitals who has beds open
when and where can we move you know who
has people in emergency departments who
have bed open beds open and can we get
them all to the right place
um the expansion in the number we call
them drf designated receiving beds um
you make sure that we have beds
available expansions in step down and
into less restrictive settings again
getting folks out the back door and then
all the way to landlord incentives so
that we have housing that's stable and
we can support landlords so that they
feel comfortable in renting to this
particular population so if we move to
um so so two things there yes I for for
the newer people uh we're responding to
um a court case a court order correct
right so this isn't just because it's
the right thing to do it's also because
we have we have to do it we we have a
legal obligation to do this and then
it's my understanding correct me if I'm
wrong that if we I I I I hear the whole
systems Pipeline and all the things
you're doing to to improve the pipeline
throughout perfect thinking but if we
could only do one thing is it true that
the number one thing we have to do is
clear out the New Hampshire hospital be
able to handle discharges more
effectively uh and and that means we
have to have places for those people to
go is that really the heart of the
biggest part of the problem that is one
of them I don't know that I I'm
comfortable saying that's it but it's
critically important and that's the work
that we're really focused on we're
focused on all of it the care traffic
control was incredibly important to be
able to match resources that I I don't
want to understate that and it's a real
systems if you want to go back and like
lean it or what or denting it um that
was really important but ultimately
there has to be a place that's safe for
people to go when they leave the
hospital and so that they can leave the
hospital right I I I'm not minimizing
all the great work to to do to see have
the visibility over the workflow I that
was beautiful that was good that's great
I'm just thinking that the next big
thing that we do that may have the
biggest budgetary impact is clearing out
the New Hampshire hospital and having
places to go it's it's the having the
place to go I'm worried about the money
too I mean obviously the workflow is
important but you know we need you to
help us understand uh where the the the
biggest cash issue is and and what is
what we're going to do so if you look at
the the next slide afterwards I I don't
I've lost my numbers on the slide but um
really that's says MZ strategy
description funding this is an example
of again those items that we need to do
and it this is how we've had to leverage
all those different sources of funds so
for example the landlord incentives have
been really helpful it's relatively
small numbers um but it's the way that
you get people into sta into stable
housing that you're not and in a less
restrictive stable housing is to be able
to make sure that landlords know that
they have someone to call that they have
a little bit of skin in the game as well
to making sure that we've got great
housing available or appropriate housing
available for people to ultimately live
in so that they can Thrive and stay in
the community rather than needing
expensive um uh acute care and more
importantly that they don't have a need
for that level of acute care I I think
represent wner did you have a question
yes I did I did have a question so I
can't keep my eyes off this one and I
this goes back a couple of pages so this
one slide of eight out of T eight out of
the 10 Mental Health Centers they seem
so important to all the work of keeping
people in the community and not into
higher end care and I'm wondering how
severe
are these losses are any of these mental
health centers in a situation where we
would lose them so I don't think we're I
it is not my understanding that we're in
a place right now where we're in Dire
Straits but the can there is a canary in
the coal mine saying you know we're
seeing red we're seeing brackets and
we're seeing red in spreadsheets and
that's always concerning and these are
you know organizations that have
thoughtful boards that understand how
they work so that's concerning to us um
we don't want to see them slide anymore
into larger and larger deficits there's
an you know and it's eight we have two
that are not in operational losses um
one of the you know we only gave that $5
million or split that $5 million among
nine of them so we're working with them
to monitor those um those financials uh
and we also are working with them to
make sure that they're doing their own
work to figure out how to have a model
that's sustainable so I don't want to
ring a bell and say that someone's
closing tomorrow I don't want to suggest
that but it's enough that we should be
paying
attention thank you yep thank you
so uh how do we know Mission zero is
working this is a great example we're
often asked how are we accountable we're
Ma we're watching the data we have great
um online tools that all of you can also
look at when you look at this slide that
has this great line we have gone from
what was um back in 2023 an average of
44 individuals waiting in um hospital
emergency rooms down to I would say
suggest that it's less than 20 this is a
little bit old but an average of less
than 20 knowing that we get to we have
gotten to zero on individual days
sometimes those numbers bounce up and
down it's the reason we flatten it out
with that red line um we have seen that
small uptick in um designated receiving
facility beds drf beds we've seen that
move up we've seen that within our own
hospital um Ellen Leo who's the CEO of
New Hampshire hospital has done
extraordinary work um in making sure
that we have as many beds online as
possible at New Hampshire hospital but
this is also with our other partners
other hospitals in the state that also
have their own beds so we're seeing that
while it's not a dramatic slope every
bed is important when you're looking at
20 people waiting that's a small end so
each bed matters in there and with just
even the inclusion of a few more we
continue to get that number of
individuals waiting in the emergency
room to decrease importantly I love the
green bar graph as well because it shows
how you know just even in um febru from
February AR to December in 2024 we went
from a weight of an average of about 4
days down to a wait to about a day and a
half that's incredible progress to me as
well so while the inflow continues we're
seeing the num the amount of time
waiting decrease incredibly important it
this an emergency room is no place to be
when you're in a mental health crisis
whether you're an adult or a child and
we want to make sure that they're
getting into the appropriate level of
care so I'm I'm on my last two slot I
want to say something for we have
members of the committee that I don't
know have ever spent much time uh
walking around in an emergency room and
and seeing what the operation of an
emergency room is like but but having
people uh in a weight category for
mental health in the corridor of an
emergency room this this is barbaric
this is the kind of thing that happens
in third world Nations and so so I think
not only the court order but good care
and just making sure our ERS are
functional to handle emergency triage
situations and all the like I I I I
think that uh I really appreciate the
way the commissioner and the everyone's
been addressing this uh and I I just
want you to know I I think we need to
continue to support your efforts because
this needs to be routinely zero I think
yes absolutely it is it is what we're
all focused laser focused on and and I
don't want to um you I don't want want
to minimize I would I want to overstate
and underscore the role of our partners
in getting here both at the community
mental health centers in the hospitals
around the state Nami New Hampshire
everyone coming together around the
table and sort of airing our Dirty
Laundry together and working through
really tricky problems is what's enabled
us to make this progress and while it
doesn't may not look radical from 4 days
to a day and a half is critically
important if you're a person in need as
representative at words describ so where
I'm met on my last two slides so how do
we know all of this is working we have
our road map we're meeting our metrics
um you'll see the little check marks
we've had deliverables within our road
map that we've been able to get to um
we're thrilled around the community
behav the um we're we've got two
certified in our ccbhcs so we're almost
at that um and then finally around our
crisis stabilization locations again a
place to go to deescalate to talk to
here to get some professional help um so
that you can reduce just one more person
from having to go to the emergency room
and experience that kind of care that's
what it's all about we've got um we only
have we were hoping to have total of
four we only had enough funding for two
um and then finally around building this
right siiz Statewide system of inpatient
care and getting our transfers going we
have launched our our dashboard which is
where you saw that data we have
increased the number number of beds at
New Hampshire hospital and I can tell
you that in February just about a week
or so Dartmouth health is going to bring
five more beds online incredibly
important and with
that a question about the 185 it's
capacity is that is that staff
capability or is that potential capacity
thank you for the question Ellen Le
Point I'm the CEO at New Hampshire
hospital so you're asking about the
number of 185 and if it's dependent on
Staffing and if we can go above that so
thank you for the question so 185 is um
our capacity there are occasions where
we've been able to go above that or of
course below that as it relates
primarily to Acuity on units as well as
semi-private rooms versus private rooms
the majority of our rooms the hospital
are semi-private but as you can imagine
there are circumstances where certain
patients require private rooms so that
does sometimes have an impact on our
overall census okay so my question was
much simpler than than your answer uh I
I just want to make sure how we're using
the word capacity is this a physical
capacity or a staffed
bed physical capacity physical so so
it's probably a lesser number because
you're still de still dealing with
Workforce
issues I mean because because the next
question you can anticipate is how are
you doing on Workforce we're doing
better on Workforce our uh retention
rates are very high in comparison to
National averages but also our um our
current uh I can't think of the word
vacancy thank you vacancy rate um is a
bit higher than the department um in
general but overall we have been able to
make some progress on hiring some
additional clinical staff and of course
we are using uh contracted staff as well
so so we're today approximately where do
you think you are on staffed
beds 185 oh all right so I'm I'm having
trouble with the word capacity
apparently uh representative Daniels
thank you why do we have such a mental
health
crisis um boy wish I could answer that
question for you and and certainly not
in the 15 minutes that's left for me
today you know I think it is
so um multi there are so many reasons
multifactoral um some of it is
recognizing mental health conditions in
the way that we may not have me
recognized that in the past I think we
fundamentally as a society we want to
make sure that people have strong
Connections in their Community we know
that connections are incredibly
important um and I think the ability
ability to name and treat those
conditions so that people can have
healthy lives is is incredibly important
and to be able to get the kind of care
that's needed I I wish I could fully um
explain that there's a great couple of
um uh the surgeon the previous Surgeon
General under um the previous
administration did some great um pieces
on things like loneliness and other
contributors to mental health conditions
but man I I can't answer that question
for you in full in a way that's
appropriate thank you um I I I waited
purposely until you got done to see if
you would basically answer the question
um regard regarding
preventive measures that the department
has taken you mentioned it a little bit
but you also mentioned that the numbers
are going up particularly when you're
talking about the the four out of 10
students who felt sad or depressed um it
seems to me that maybe a major focus
should be more on prevention and not
getting people into the system because
it seems like the majority of what
you're doing I is trying to Pro provide
treatment as opposed to preventative
measur that would ever keep them from
from getting getting there so um can you
talk sure I can talk a little bit about
that you are speaking some of you know
where I am grounded in my own personal
work that I have done over time so I'm
really thankful to hear that question
and um and and have the opportunity to
explore that a little more as we do our
work not just today so you're absolutely
right part of why I haven't talked a lot
about prevention is today's Focus was
really on these areas in children youth
and families and Behavioral Health much
of that prevention work happens out in
the community and happens in places like
in public health settings or the Ed or
school and not that schools are doing
social emotional Wellness or you know
things that are scary but how are we
making sure that kids are um in settings
that are kind you know that children
learn how to be kind to each other all
of that is important early on and we
need to have strengthened families
families that have the resources they
need to to get by in the day that
they've got food and housing and they're
not as stressed out mom you know Mom and
Dad are both working that we have
appropriate child care all of those are
contributors and are part of the
prevention ecosystem that we need to
make sure that families are
and getting the um supports they need
within their communities and none of us
want uh our never none of us really want
to have people in in these systems you
know there will always be a need for
them I want to say there are conditions
in life that we are not going to be able
to get around but we want to be able to
be starting early in especially with
children to make sure that they've got
the skills that they need the resiliency
they need and that they're they have the
supports that they need that um that we
can reduce the number number coming into
those systems reduce the number coming
into the child welfare system if we can
do that that'll be incredibly important
we um the pandemic was difficult the
pandemic was socially difficult for
everyone and that's where we've seen
that Peak I am hoping we're going to
start seeing some of those numbers come
down over time so my my my final
question what's not working with the
with the preventative program we have
now if the numbers are continuing to
rise you know what that's a super
question one of the things so some of
the things are twofold do we have enough
of it are we spreading it out enough are
enough people being able to participate
in it and prevention could be everything
from going to the you know reading group
at the library with your toddler you
know it starts there it's not always a
Department of Health and Human Services
Program um although some of them might
be like our home visiting programs Our
Family Resource Centers are they scaled
appropriately is a question we should be
asking ourselves and then also are we
doing the right things that's always a
question we should be asking ourselves
and which is back to why I would like to
look even more at our data around you
know if the what are the where do we see
kids getting better and what are the
interventions that they've had and what
has been supportive in their life that
has allowed them to get better we think
um you know we are working on the
premise in dcyf that being in family
being in kin may be more protective will
always need Foster families and we love
them and they do incredible work but we
think that perhaps being within your own
family unit might provide some
additional protection and so those
outcomes we're not going to see for
years later thank
you so that reminded me I I think one of
the topics I had hoped that we would
cover as a special event was uh Public
Health did is have we talked about
having Ian and the public health folks
come in and do a okay so can can we add
that I I think we could do that sure uh
before the budget because it's a
programmatic thing and I'll go to
representative priest in a second um I I
I just want to say one of the things
that um I we I'm hearing us say is
because we're here together and we have
some capacity to solve some social ills
it it it it gets to be I think a little
natural for us to U forget the Primacy
of of families and I've heard you say it
several times so I don't think you've
forgotten but I but I but I but I think
you know in this era of uh family trauma
and uh and the postco world and some
economic stresses um I I think we almost
have to keep thinking about how do we
avoid the temptation to step in and
think we're the parents of the parents
there there there's some there's got to
be some approaches where where where we
can set up policy where families will
just naturally be stronger and better at
their job you know uh government can't
love a kid government can't you know
read a book to the kid at night so
there's there's just inherent
limitations of what we do but the
Temptation is for us all to get together
and try to solve the problems and I I I
think there's some of these issues that
are just way outside of our boundaries
but representative priest thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question out of the numbers that you are
seeing in your community health organ
mental health
organizations um what percentage are
with those individuals who have a
substance
abuse I don't know that number off the
top of my head I don't know if Kya knows
that number off the top of her head we
can get that for you but it's certainly
they are there's a lot if I did the ven
diagram there's you know there's
crossover there there's no doubt about
that I just can't tell you that number
because I just came from a hearing
where there was a discussion on recovery
beds having safe certifiable recovery
facilities for patients who have gone
out of treatment and they're looking for
a safe place for the next step and it
was shown that we need 14,000 new beds
in New Hampshire we only have
1,300
Statewide it's a problem these people
are going in treatment and then then
they're going back into treatment
because there's no that there isn't in
that next step absolutely and and in the
you know I would be here for another 12
hours boring you all to death if I had
added all of the work that we're doing
around substance misuse so that we
didn't get to talk about there today but
you're absolutely right that overlap is
tremendous and it and again that starts
in among youth thank you very
much perers in
wner mine's an announcement about the
field trip okay
okay so I've heard back from Waypoint
and the date and time we picked is fine
and I so look for an email I asked them
to email each of us with instructions on
where the shelter is where we should
Park and any other kinds of U things we
need to know about um coming into the
facility so watch for that and I ask her
if she wanted RSVP so she may be asking
you to to RSVP okay just note that that
particular program is an incredible is
an incredible and integral part of this
our system of care as well and
especially again another conversation I
could have is that really sensitive time
of the transition to adulthood between a
child serving system into young
adulthood the other thing I'll just note
to you on your um desk I think I said I
think I noted that this is our um ages
in rep um to answer representative
Daniel's question around what age do we
serve if you look at the back you'll see
some of the supports that we provide to
young adults coming out of the dcyf
system knowing that that launching
period is critically important and
Waypoint does a great job with um their
there a represent I just have a quick
question I came in a few minutes late
and I just want to double check on the
agenda um it said we were going to hear
about individuals with disabilities is
that the staffer who was unavailable
today so we will have that coming thank
you
all right so um are there any other
questions from the
committee uh do you have any last words
for us anything you thought that we
should have heard that you didn't get a
chance to say no I just hope that
everyone walks away having heard us
talking about this need to make sure to
think about those triangles again and I
think that's been the conversation
around the table around what's the
appropriate scaling of resources for
both our acute needs and the
preventative needs and getting the right
need right programs to the right people
um we want to serve people when people
have to be served to your point when
people have a need we want to be able to
do that as close to home whether you're
a kid or whether you're an adult
experiencing a mental health crisis and
we appreciate all of the Investments
that have been made over time to help us
get there so thank you uh you're welcome
um is there anyone in the audience that
would like to say something before we
break huddle
here I don't see any Mr Ripple I always
like to finish with you how are we doing
it do I forget anything I don't think so
so just to confirm though you're looking
for presentations on Public Health
Developmental services and elderly and
adult and a continuation of it and
Contracting that's what I'm thinking
okay so um you know uh and I'm sorry
there was just a little uh extra one in
there I do think we need a focus on uh
the transition from uh cunu to the new
Youth Development Center and I need we
need to um deal with the the the
Manpower a little bit more deeply to
understand that sure I'll add that okay
all right uh anything else so with that
um I I'll adjourn I think we've got a a
a a little talk here in a bit okay all
right with that uh we are adjourned